Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Ahmet Tutoglu. Ich arbeite hier aus Asistan Assetik und würde gerne mit Ihnen
diese Aufnahme geschickt führen. Bitte fragen Sie nach einem Set, das nicht verstehen.
Wie heißt es? Ich heiße Magdalena Schmidt.
Magdalena Schmidt. Schmidt mit 2T am Ende. 2T. OK. Magdalena MAGDLNA.
Wie heißt es? Ich heiße Magdalena. OK. Und Schmidt? Schmidt mit I und 2T. I und 2T. OK. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin noch 55 Jahre. 55. 55. OK. Waren Sie sich genau geboren? Am 11. Juni 66. 66. OK. Wie schwer sind Sie?
79 kg. 79. Wie groß sind Sie? 1,68 m. 1,68 m. OK. Frau Schmidt, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ja, also mein rechter Arm ist seit einigen Tagen geschwollen und das wird immer schlimmer und der Arm ist auch gerötet und das tut mir auch weh und der ist ganz, ganz warm und die Haut glänzt.
Ich kann den auch gar nicht mehr richtig besiegen. Das spandt alles so. Das ist ganz unangenehm. Und jetzt habe ich gedacht, das muss ich doch mal in einem Arzt zeigen.
OK. Seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Ja, das hat angefangen. Vielleicht so vor, ganz schwach hat es angefangen vor 10 Tagen, 12 Tagen vielleicht und dann habe ich das aber erst gar nicht so ernst genommen und jetzt wird es halt schlimmer und jetzt habe ich gedacht, muss ich das doch mal zeigen.
Gibt es eine, wenn er wundert?
Nein, ist mir nicht aufgefallen. Nein.
OK, oder eine Stich haben Sie gesehen?
Ein Strich habe ich auch nicht gesehen. Nein.
OK.
OK, Ihre Rechter haben geschwollen, gerötet. OK, wie stark Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkohl 1 sehr leicht und 10 sehr stark entschlickt?
Schwer zu sagen, das sind keine, manchmal ist dieses Spannungsgefühl so unangenehm, aber die Schmerzen vielleicht so bei 6 würde ich sagen zwischen 5 und 6.
OK.
Ich schone den Arm halt, ich schone ihn und dann tut es halt nicht weh, wenn ich ihn bewegen würde, wäre es vielleicht schlimmer.
Sie können nicht bewegen, oder? Nein, ich kann den gar nicht mehr bewegen.
OK.
Diese Schmerzen, wie es, könnten Sie mir das beschreiben, ist das steckend oder dumpf oder...
Er drückend und ein Spannungsschmerz.
Spannungsschmerz.
Spannungsgefühl und drückender Schmerz, ja.
OK.
Aber Sie haben gesagt, es gibt Schwellung dort.
Ja.
Ganzer Arm oder?
Ja, ja. Also die Hände sind auch so ein bisschen, dass ich die Finger nicht bewegen kann, das zieht schon runter in den ganzen Arm.
Ganzer Arm.
OK.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Auslöser gemerkt?
Nein, ist mir jetzt nichts aufgefallen, sonst...
Nein, ich kann jetzt nicht sagen, was da der Hintergrund ist.
OK.
OK, danke.
Haben Sie Fieber auch?
Fieber ist mir nicht auch, weil ich fühle mich nicht fieberig und ich habe mich allerdings auch nicht gemessen, muss ich sagen.
OK.
Haben Sie Schutterfrust?
Schüttelrost hatte ich auch nicht, nein.
OK.
Vor dieser Beschwerden haben Sie irgendwelche Infektionen oder anstreckende Probleme gehabt oder?
Die hatte letzter Zeit? Nein.
Also letzte Mal, dass ich irgendwie ernsthaft im Krankenhaus war oder so, das war vor einem Jahr wegen der Hüft-Tab, aber sonst, dass die anderen Sachen liegen,
alle viel länger zurück.
OK.
OK, jetzt, ich habe eine Frage für Ihre Argumentus stand.
Haben Sie sich da keine Lust bemerkt?
Du hast es mir nicht aufgefallen, nein.
OK.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Schwindelig, nein.
Nein.
OK.
Haben Sie Überkeit?
Überkeit?
Ja.
Nein.
OK.
Ich habe viel mehr gefühlt.
Ja.
Haben Sie Erbrochen?
Nein.
OK.
Waren Sie in der letzten Zeit an Reise oder?
Auf einer Reise?
Nein.
Nein, zurzeit ist man ja viel zu Hause.
Nein, ich war irgendwo.
OK.
Wie sieht es mit dem Wasserlassen?
Das ist ganz normal, wie immer.
Stuhlgang?
Auch.
Da habe ich keine Probleme.
OK.
Ja, Sie haben gesagt, Sie wurden operiert.
Hüft-Tab, richtig?
Das ist vor einem Jahr gewesen, genau.
Vor einem Jahr, ja.
Und gibt es andere Operationen?
Ja, tatsächlich habe ich vor 14 Jahren eine Brustoperation gehabt.
Wegen Brustkrebs.
Brustkrebs.
OK.
Wann waren Sie in der letzten Zeit mit Ihrem Arzt für diese Brustkrebs?
Ich war in den letzten 3 Monaten in einer gynäkologischen Kontrolle.
Und da war alles in Ordnung.
3 Monate?
Alles in Ordnung?
Ja.
Sie haben operiert, ja?
Das ist operiert worden, ja, genau.
Nur 2 Operationen, oder?
Ja, genau.
Haben Sie vorher krank, oder?
Ja, ich habe seit 14 Jahren ein bisschen Bluthochdruck.
Und die Fette, die Kolesterolinwerte sind auch ein bisschen erhöht.
Das hat man jetzt vor 9 Jahren festgestellt.
Und ich versuche da ein bisschen vernünftig zu sein mit dem Essen,
aber das hat ja eigentlich nicht viel Einfluss.
Aber, also das ist nichts Dramatisches.
Und als Kind hatte ich tatsächlich so die Infektionskrankheiten,
Röteln hatte ich und Mums.
Aber das ist ja schon wirklich sehr, sehr lange her.
OK.
Bluthochdruck, seit wann haben Sie live?
Seit 14 Jahren.
14, OK.
Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie für diese Bluthochdruck?
Ja, ich nehme Konko 5 und Diobahn 160, je morgens eine.
Konko 5 und Diobahn.
Diobahn 160.
160.
OK.
Für diese Covesterin?
Dann nehme ich nichts, da versuche ich nur vernünftig zu essen.
OK.
Aber tatsächlich habe ich ja ein bisschen Übergewicht
und ich habe auch in den letzten Monaten 2 kg zugenommen.
Obwohl ich mir eigentlich andere Mühe gegeben habe.
2 kg zugenommen.
OK, wie ist die Lappatid jetzt?
Der ist eigentlich schon gut meistens.
OK.
Jetzt kommen wir zur Allergien.
Haben Sie Allergien gegen Medikamente, Konfliktsmittel oder Staub?
Ja, ich habe tatsächlich Heuschnupfen gegen Medikamente,
wüsste ich jetzt nicht.
Aber ich habe Heuschnupfen und deswegen nehme ich bei Bedarf Zitrizin.
OK.
Bei Bedarf nehmen Sie.
Genau.
Haben Sie keine,
weil nicht Allergien andere dafür sind.
Sonst wüsste ich nicht nö, sonst nichts bekannt an Allergien.
Vertragung Sie alle Lebensmittel,
gut oder zumbasch,
umzunehmen, fructose oder lactose.
Ja, bisher ist da nichts bekannt.
OK, gut.
Jetzt kommen wir ihre Familie.
Sind ihre Eltern noch?
Mein Vater ist früh gestorben,
hat den Herzen schagt mit 54,
aber meine Mutter lebt noch,
die hat auch eine Hüftgelenkprothese
und hat genauso wie ich auch,
also Hypertonus,
und ist aber, damit kommt sie jetzt ganz gut zurecht.
Hypertonus.
Hypertoni, also Gluthochdruck.
Ja, Hyperton.
Genau wie ich auch.
OK.
Wie meine Schwester?
Ja, die sind beide auch ordentlich mitgenommen.
Mein Bruder hatte vor vier Jahren auch einen Herzenfakt,
hat den aber ganz gut überstanden.
Und bei meiner Schwester hat man vor einem Jahr
auch Brustkrebs festgestellt.
OK.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe drei Kinder.
OK.
Und drei Kinder.
Sind Ihre Kinder gesund?
Die sind alle fit, ja, zum Glück.
OK.
Und ein Kerl Kinder?
Auch, ja.
Ja, wunderbar, was ist da mit?
Ja, Frau Schmidt, rauchen Sie?
Nee, zum Glück nicht.
OK, drin ist Alkohol.
Gelegentlich mal ein Glas Sechs oder ein Glas Wein
oder im Sommer mal ein Bier, wenn es heiß ist oder so.
Aber also nicht regelmäßig.
Nicht regelmäßig.
Gelegentlich zum Beispiel ein oder zweimal pro Woche?
Das würde ja alles hauptsächlich.
OK.
Bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht über.
Ja.
Probieren Sie, haben Sie Drogen probiert?
Nee, nie.
War ich immer zu feige dazu.
OK, sehr gut.
Ja, Sie haben drei Kinder.
Sind Sie verheiratet oder?
Ja, ja, ja.
Und ich lebe mit meiner Familie zusammen, ja.
Also die Kinder sind natürlich Erwachsene
und sind aus dem Haus, ne?
Ja.
OK.
Arbeiten Sie?
Ich bin Reiseverkehrskauf-Frau, arbeite im Reisebüro.
Reise?
Im Reisebüro.
Reisever...
Verkehrskauf-Frau.
Reiseverkehrskauf-Frau.
Kauf-Frau.
OK.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Ihrer Arbeit oder?
Ja, im Augenblick läuft halt nicht viel wegen Corona.
Im Augenblick sind wir in...
Wie heißt das?
Ah, es freut mich das Wort nicht ein.
Also, ja.
Arbeiten wir halt weniger, aber grundsätzlich macht das schon sehr viel Spaß.
Und ich hoffe, dass es bald wieder losgeht.
OK, danke.
Frau Schmidt.
OK.
Ich möchte eine Sammelfassung machen.
Seit 10 Tagen haben Sie Schwellungen auf Ihre rechte Arme, richtig?
Schwellung auf rechten Armen, ja.
Ja.
Und dort haben Sie Rötung und Wärme gemerkt, auch.
Und Schmerzen haben Sie.
Ja.
Und haben das geschrieben, dass Sie operiert haben für Brustkrebs.
OK.
Seit 40 Jahren.
Und auch Hüfte.
OK.
Und haben Sie Bluthochdruck und Hypercholesterin.
Ja.
OK.
Und haben Sie Häuschen mitzunehmen?
Ja.
Und Häuschen mitzunehmen, ja, genau.
Möchten Sie irgendeine welche Linke hinzufügen?
Mir fällt tatsächlich ein, da war ja noch eine gynecologische OK.
Vor vier Jahren hatte ich ein Myom in der Gebärmutter.
Das ist auch noch operiert worden.
Sehen Sie, das ist mir ganz entfallen vor lauter andern Sachen.
Myom, Operation, vier Jahre.
Genau.
Und Gebärmutter total ein Femd oder?
Nein, nein, nein.
Nur das Myom ist entfernt.
Nur das Myom, OK.
OK, OK, dann.
Sie können ein bisschen warten und ich möchte mit meinem Oberarzt sprechen.
Aber erstens möchte ich Ihnen körperlich untersuchen, ja.
OK, ja.
Und was meinen Sie denn, was dahinterstecken kann?
Was kann das denn sein?
Ist das etwas Gefährliches?
OK.
Auserstens denke ich, das kann von Ihren Brustkrebs gekommen.
Aber das ist doch so lange her.
Ja, aber manchmal Komplikationen kommen sehr,
ja, manchmal können wir Komplikationen zahlgen, ja.
Nicht, äh, kürzlich.
Ja, deswegen.
OK.
Ich dachte das.
Aber natürlich, nach dem Unterzlichen Unterzug und Luteabnahme
und ja, außer dem, äh, eine Ultraschalluntersuchung.
Ah ja, was kann man da sehen in der Ultraschalluntersuchung?
Wie bitte?
Was kann man in der Ultraschalluntersuchung sehen?
Ah, OK.
Ja, auserstens, ich möchte auf Doppler-Utersuchung,
äh, machen.
Sie möchten eine Doppler-Untersuchung machen?
Ja, Doppler-Utersuchung.
Ja, wir können Ihre Gefäße gut sehen mit diesem Tropfen.
Ah, OK.
OK, und dann, äh, wir können über das, äh, die Ihre Situation gut
sprechen, ich denke.
OK, gut.
Ja, dann warte ich jetzt.
OK, ja.
OK, gut.
Wollen wir ein bisschen Vorbereitung oder?
Ähm, ja, ein bisschen.
Ja, dann gucken wir.
Vielleicht.
Welche hat ja jemand noch Fragen von den Kolleginnen und Kollegen?
Ja, ich habe eine Frage.
Würden auch die Linksknoten im Axelbereich während der OP entfand?
Ja, ich unterstelle ich jetzt mal, dass das gemacht worden ist.
Ich habe da zwar keine Info dazu, aber ich nehme stark an, dass es so ist, ja.
Haben Sie nachlich-häsch-schmerzen oder ruh-häsch-schmerzen?
Noch mal.
Nächliche Schmerzen?
Ja, nachlich-häsch-schmerzen.
Nächliche Schmerzen oder ruh-schmerzen?
Ja.
Oh, bo, bo, bo, bo.
Ja, nachts.
Ja, so schlimm sind die Schmerzen nicht.
Ich konnte wohl überwiegend schlafen, aber eigentlich sind die Schmerzen schon zunehmend
und sind ruh-schmerzen, ja.
Genau.
Und sind dauerhaft, ja.
Können Sie Ihr Arm hoch-häben?
Nein, das geht nicht gut.
Ich muss den praktisch mit der anderen Hand hochheben.
Der fühlt sich so schwer an und das spandt auf alles, weil das alles geschwollen ist.
Okay.
Leiden Sie häufig unter Infektion und der betroffenen Körperregion?
Bisher hatte ich das noch nie, nein.
Okay, dann ist die Situation seitdem unverändert
oder kann das Schwellung durch Hochlagerung zum Beispiel vermindert werden?
Ja, eigentlich ganz bisschen wird es durch Hochlagerung besser, aber nicht grundlegend.
Okay.
Wurde Ihre Blut, Ihr Blut aus Ihren rechten Arm eintnommen?
Ja, gute Frage.
Nein, nein, nein, das hat man mir gesagt, dass ich Blut immer Blut entnahmen und Blutdruck messen,
immer am linken Arm machen soll.
Haben Sie Krippen oder Tapeis gefreut?
Nee, das ist mir jetzt nicht aufgefallen.
Aber Sie erinnern, hatten Sie Unfall vor einigen Tagen?
Unfall hatte ich nicht, nein, nein, das ist nichts passiert.
Sind Sie auf den rechten Arm gefallen?
Nein, also kann ich mich nicht erinnern.
Können wir?
Ja, gut.
Vielleicht können wir auch fragen, ob die Rötung scharf begrenzt ist auf der Haut?
Ja, es sieht glaube ich tatsächlich nicht.
Okay.
Ich möchte Ihnen eine Patientin vorstellen, habe Sie Zeit für mich?
Aber ja, den haben Sie denn gesehen?
Okay.
Magdalenna Schimit, 55 Jahre alt, 79 kg und 168 cm.
Sie kommen mit uns seit 10 Tagen aufgetreten,
auf rechterarme Schwellung, Bärme und Rötung.
Und Schmerzen auch.
Auf einer Schmerzsegala, es ist auf 6 und 10.
Sie haben jetzt Bewerbung, Beschränkungen auch hier.
Bewegungseinschränkungen.
Okay.
Und die Bewerberationen waren das 2 kg Zunahme.
Und die Fabrik gefühlt.
Fabrik gefühlt?
Ja, Fabrik gefühlt.
Und bei den Vorerkrankungen haben die Patientin operiert
mit der Hyftep vor 1 Jahr und Brustkrebs vor 15 Jahren.
Und außerdem mit Operationen seit vor 4 Jahren.
Auf welcher Seite ist denn die Brust-OP gewesen?
Auf welcher Seite war die Brust-OP?
Ja, ich frag mich.
Okay, kann man ja nachher bei der körperlichen Untersuchung mal unauffällig gucken.
Ja.
Okay.
Und außerdem haben die Patientin Arterelle Hypertonie seit 14 Jahren
und Hypertokolesterin Emmi seit 10 Jahren.
Sie nehmen Konkord 5 mg und Dioban 180 mg für gegen Arterelle Hypertonie.
Außer dem haben die Patientin allerergin, sie haben Koischenöpfung
und wogegen Neemesistiatrisin bei Bedarf.
Und die Familienanamnese ergraben sich beim Vater Herzinfarkt
und bei der Mutter Hyftep und Arterelle Hypertonie,
beim Bruder Herzinfarkt und bei Schwester Brustkrebs auch.
Die Patienten rauchst nicht, aber gelegentlich trinken sie
einmal oder zweimal provokte ein Wein oder ein Bier.
Und schließlich, die Patientin sind sehr verheiratet,
haben drei Kinder und leben mit ihrer Familie,
arbeiten als Reiseverkaufsfrau.
Reiseverkehrskaufsv? Ja, okay.
Ja, Reiseverkehrskaufsv.
Aufgrund Erwandtenangaben gehe ich von einer Verdachtdiagnose auf Lampfangitis.
Lampfangitis? Lampfangitis.
Okay. Was wäre differential diagnostisch?
Alternativ kommt TvT.
Im Betracht.
Aufgrund Erwandtenangaben müssen nach der körperlichen Untersuchung
Blutflusslabors abgenommen und die Personografie.
Ja, sorry.
Was ist das, woher gucken Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung besonders?
Okay, auserst ist, welche Brust passt.
Okay, ja.
Diese Patientin operiert worden und auserst ist das.
Und soweit ist, ich möchte diese schweren Rundenrötchen sägen
und ich möchte die Brust kontrollieren.
Die Pulse, ja, sehr gut.
Ein ganz einfaches Verfahren bietet sich eigentlich an,
um die Schwellung zu verifizieren.
Könnten Sie fragen, um die Schwellung nachzuweisen?
Ja, wir können das messen.
Ja, mit Zentimeter, wir können messen.
Auf verschiedenen Messpunkten.
Und dann vergleichen, wie wir den rechten Arm,
einen Referenzpunkt nehmen.
Und dann mit dieser Referenzpunkt,
wir können mit 10 Zentimeter langen.
Und dann messen wir das auch.
Und dann vergleichen die beiden Arme,
inwieweit die Schwellung auffällig ist.
Ja, ich möchte Alternativdiagnose hinzufügen.
Ein Brusttrebs, wie sagen wir das?
Rezidiv?
Ja.
Meinen Sie Rezidiv?
Ja, nicht Rezidiv, aber Brustkrebs, wiederkommt.
Rezidiv?
Ja.
Wenn etwas wiederkommt, ist es ein Rezidiv?
Ja, Rezidiv.
Und deswegen auch.
Wir können diesen Reschwert unsägen.
Ja, okay.
Wovon gucken Sie im Labor besonders?
Okay.
Als erstes Blutbild und ein Zündungsparameter auch hier.
Was machen Sie für eine operative Untersuchung?
Ich möchte das machen.
Als erstes, ich dachte das.
Und dann, ja, das ist die erste, zweite.
Und wo nach gucken Sie beim Doppler?
Doppler, wir können das Brachialartärcht kontrollieren.
Ja, also einmal das Gefühlsystem.
Aber was können wir noch sehen, Ultraschall?
Ja, mit der Motorchall-Aussurwärm können wir sagen,
diese Unterhaut gibt es dort Flüssigkeiten, oder?
Wir können das sagen.
Sehr gut.
Ja, dann bin ich wirklich gespannt, was rauskommt.
Jetzt für den Fall, dass die Patientin tatsächlich eine
Windrombose hat in dem Arm.
Oder eine Windrombose.
Ja, das ist eine sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr,
sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr,
sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr,
sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr,
sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr,
sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr,
sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr,
Wir können als erstes mit ISS anfangen.
Eine Nummer höher.
Niedermolekulare Saffari.
Ja, Heparin.
Wir können ja Heparin.
Also tief in Trombose im Arm, genau so behandelt wie tief in Trombose im Bein.
Okay.
Ja, das machen wir noch.
Was machen wir noch?
Wir haben neue Medikamente zum Beispiel Zarelto oder?
Zarelto. Ja, okay.
Das für später dann, ne?
Aber das andere, damit fangen wir an und gucken.
Ja, aber was machen wir denn noch außer der Medikation?
Okay, wir machen die Armhöhe nehmen.
Hochlagerung, ja.
Ja, Lagerung.
Und Bandage auch.
Ja, genau, das ist ein Kompressionsverband.
Ja, Kompressionsverband.
Und für die Dauer, was kriegt ihr statt ihrem Verband später?
Wir können die Schwellung und Kontrolle nehmen.
Ja.
Oder wird immer gewickelt?
Wie bitte?
Wird dann immer bandagiert, wird immer gewickelt, oder gibt es eine Alternative?
Ja, Alternative.
Ja, wir können auch künomatische Kompressionen, aber das ist, ich denke,
im früheren Zeitung, das ist, das kann gefährlich, oder?
Also, man muss erst abwarten, bis die Schwellung, bis der Arm wieder runter ist.
Also, solange man Kompressionsverband machen muss.
Und wenn der Arm abgeschwollen ist, dann sollte man aber weiter komprimieren.
Und dann kann man eben einen Armstrumpf anlessen.
Also, gibt es hier auch Armstrumpf.
Und je nachdem, wenn es tatsächlich nur eine Trompose im Oberarm oder so,
könnte man das machen, dass man die Hand ausspart.
Gut.
Und wenn wir jetzt sehen, die Hand ist auch balloniert und dick.
Was machen wir denn dann?
Das bedeutet, wir haben jetzt Probleme mit Blutdruck.
Ja.
Deswegen müssen wir diese Komplession entfernen.
Ja, bitte.
Wir müssen die Hand mit einwickeln.
Ja.
Die muss die Hand, muss die Hand auch komprimiert werden.
Und man muss das halt anpassen.
Damit, ja.
Okay.
Gut.
Ja, wenn es jetzt keine Trompose ist, sondern Sie finden
erweiterte Flüssigkeit spalten.
Was ist es denn dann?
Das kann recurrence sein.
Brustkrebs recurrence sein.
Ich denke, also okay.
Im Rezitiv, weiß ich.
Ich denke noch an etwas anderes.
Okay.
Sie haben eigentlich etwas ganz Ähnliches.
Sie haben gesagt, Lymphanbietis.
Ja, ich habe das gesagt.
Aber wenn der Arm geschwollt ist, ist es ja ein Lymph-Edem.
Ja.
Aber Lymph-Edem, gut.
Aber Lymph-Edem, wir sehen, wie diese nicht mit Rötungen
oder Wärme.
Ja.
Ja, was könnte es denn dann unter Umständen sein?
Was kann es denn dann sein,
wenn es eine Rötung und Schwellung haben und die sich tatsächlich
auch fieberig fühlt?
Das bedeutet, es gibt eine Infektion auch.
Ja, und wie nennt man das?
Cellulitis.
Nee.
Erresipel.
Genau.
Erresipel, ja.
Erresipel.
Und also, ja, okay.
Jetzt muss ich tatsächlich ein bisschen aus dem Nähe-Kestchen
sagen, dass es so viele Hinweise gekommen sind, die zeigen,
dass ganz viele Bescheid wissen über Lymph-Edem und die
Erkrankungen.
Denn das ist also hier zumindest wirklich eine Geschichte,
die von den Ärzten sehr stiefmütterlich behandelt wird.
Und ich habe tatsächlich in einer gefäßcherogegenen
Erteilung gearbeitet, habe ich ja mal erzählt.
Und wir hatten über 10 Jahre, hatten wir eine Lymph-Klinik in einem
kleinen Ort hier in der Nachbarschaft und haben Patienten mit
Lymph-Edem behandelt, dort statt so näher und haben aber auch ganz
viele Leute ambulant gesehen.
Und das ist unglaublich, wie viele Gynäkologen Frauen
operieren, ohne ihnen zu sagen, dass es hinterher ein Lymph-Edem
geben kann.
Ja, und genau das, was sie gesagt haben, das kann unter
Umständen aus heiteren Himmel auftreten nach 12 Jahren, 14
Jahren.
Die denken gar nicht mehr dran, dass sie diesen rechten Armen
schonen sollen und dann haben die einmal eine schwere Einkaufstasche
getragen oder ein Wassereimer oder Kartoffeln oder im
Garten gearbeitet.
Und zack geht der Armen mit einmal hoch und keiner denkt mehr
daran, was der Hintergrund war.
Und genauso mit dem Irresipel.
Ich war begeistert, dass irgendjemand gesagt hat, wo ist das
Blut abgenommen worden?
Ja, tatsächlich denken die Leute nach 10 Jahren nicht
bei dran, dass an dem Arm kein Blut abgenommen werden soll
oder auch kein Druck gemessen werden soll.
Ja, sondern das kommt dann irgendwann in Vergessenheit
und zack, das kann Auslöser sein.
Also die Blutentnahme oder auch tatsächlich eine minimale
Verletzung für ein Irresipel.
Und dann aus dem Irresipel folgen das Lymph-Edem
und das Lymph-Edem als Spiel-Edem.
Als Spielfolge eben auch ohne eine Wunde tatsächlich.
Na ja, wobei da muss man eben auch, will ich sagen,
die Frage nach einer Verletzung ist okay.
Aber nochmal gucken ist tatsächlich nochmal was anderes.
Denn da langen ja so ganz winzige Sachen, wie jetzt im Winter
so Raggaden in der Haut oder an den Fingerlegeln,
weil die Haut trocken ist und weil man irgendwie Gemüse geputzt hat
oder so, ja, und ganz, ganz kleine Stellen in der Haut
reichen aus als Eintrittsforten für das Irresipel.
Und ja, also ich bin wirklich sehr begeistert,
weil tatsächlich mein Chef hat seinerzeit irgendwie in seinen
Vorträgen immer gesagt, durchsätzlich dauert es sieben
Jahre bis ein Lymph-Edem richtig diagnostiziert wird.
Also ist es besonders bei Bein-Lymph-Edem, ja,
weil die Leute werden auf alles Mögliche behandelt,
was ich mal sage, die sollen abnehmen oder die Füße hochlegen
oder Wort auch über, ja.
Und dann kriegen die halt keine angemessene Behandlung
und bis zur Diagnose im Schnitt sieben Jahre,
das ist schon wirklich öde.
Und ja, was brauchen wir denn dann für einen Kompressionsstrumpf,
wenn es ein Lymph-Edem ist?
Nehmen wir den ganz normalen Kompressionsstrumpf?
Ja, es gibt, ja, es gibt unterschiedliche,
ich habe das gesehen, zwei oder drei,
Hochdruckkompressions.
Also das Problem ist, das Problem ist,
es gibt zwei verschiedene Arten,
die strümpfe gestrickt sind.
Die einen sind rundgestrickt,
das sind die, die man bei Wien-Trombose nimmt
und die man also auch bei einer Arm-Wien-Trombose nimmt
und dann gibt es den flachgestrickten Strumpf,
der nach Maß angefertigt werden muss
und der Haken ist, das schnürt sich nicht ein.
Ein rundgestrickter Armstrumpf würde sich
bei so einem geschwollenen Arm oder Bein
eben reinziehen und dann kriegen die so Furchen praktisch,
ja, wie so eine Wurstpelle, die zu eng ist, ja.
Und das ist dann eher kontraproduktiv,
das macht es nur noch schlimmer
und die haben noch mehr Schmerzen
und der flachgestrickte Strumpf hat halt,
die muss halt eine sehr gute Passform haben
und muss auch immer wieder erneuert werden,
wenn sich der Arm verändert,
aber er hält das Ideen eben zusammen
und darf eben auch nur ausgemessen werden,
nachdem der Arm entstaut worden ist.
So, wie kriegt man den Arm denn entstaut?
Entstaut?
Entstaut, also wie kriegt man denn das Ideen nach Haus?
Außer durch die Bandagen.
Ah, okay.
Ja, wir haben, ja, die Reise ist unmöglich, ich denke.
Nein, es gibt manuelle Lymphfrenage.
Ja, manuelle.
Und auch plenomatisch auch.
Genau, die Plenomatische gibt es auch, ja.
Wobei zu so einer,
diese Plenomatische ist eher so geeignet,
so eine Befunderhaltung, so, ne?
Oder ja, auch speziell bei Law
in die so ein Lippe dem haben.
Aber die manuelle Lymphfrenage
ist tatsächlich für die chronischen Lymphpatienten
fast unersetzlich, ne?
Was tatsächlich ein großes Kostenproblem ist in der,
im Alltag, ne?
Weil das natürlich teuer ist, ne?
Und tatsächlich machen das auch
nicht viele Physiopraxen perfekt.
Das muss schon sehr, sehr gut gemacht werden,
dass die erste Lymphfrenage machen
und anschließend dann eben
einen sehr guten Kompressionsverband aufbringen.
Der, der das schafft,
den Arm jetzt oder das Ideen zu stabilisieren,
ohne einzuschnüren.
Da muss gut unterfüttert werden
mit so einem Watte-Flies,
bevor dann die eigentliche Kompression drauf kommt,
damit die Haut nicht leidet.
Und wenn dann der Arm abgeschwollen ist
durch diese Maßnahmen,
dann kann man den flachgestrickten Strumpf anpassen.
Also das ist so ein ganz wichtiger Zusammenarbeit
zwischen Physiotherapeuten,
also Ärztenphysiotherapeuten
und dann dem versorgenden Sanitätshaus.
Genau.
Ja, der kam gerade nochmal per
Einländung der Hinweisen,
rund- und flachgestrickte Kompressionsware.
Das ist der Unterschied.
Ja.
Ja, ich gebe zu.
Ich war sehr begeistert,
ein Beispiel zu finden aus unserem Fachbereich,
wo wir so viel gearbeitet haben.
Weil das wirklich stiefmütterlich behandelt wird,
ganz ehrlich.
Und die Information der Patienten
ist nicht besonders toll.
Genauso wie Frauen nicht informiert werden
nach Brust-OP,
sagt man, dass Männer nicht
die große Prostata-OP haben.
Da passiert genau das Gleiche möglicherweise,
dass die mit einmal ein dickes Bein kriegen
und überhaupt nicht wissen, wie ihnen geschieht.
Und es hat sich keiner aufgeklärt,
dass das eine denkbare Komplikation ist.
Ja, genauso wie es natürlich eine Komplikation
nach jedem, also großen,
großen traumatischen Eingriff.
Da kann das natürlich auch immer passieren.
Ja, wunderbar.
Gut.
Ja, also,
ja, ich bin begeistert,
dass wir da so viel zusammengetragen haben.
Und, ja,
eine Sache,
eine Sache ist mir aufgefallen,
sprachlich.
Die Familienanamnese ergab sich.
Entweder sagt man, in der Familienanamnese ergab sich,
oder die Familienanamnese
ergab.
Dann ohne sich.
Also die Familienanamnese ergab
bei der Mutter, wie Papo beim Vater.
Ja, so.
Gut, aber ich fand,
die Verständigung war gut
und die Kommunikation lief auch gut.
Ja, wann ist die Prüfung?
15. Februar.
Ach so, das ist ja wirklich schon sehr bald.
Ja, guck mal, dann erklärt sich,
dass der auch rauskommt.
Okay, das sind auch 14 Tage.
Ja, genau.
Ja, aber das soll wohl laufen, denke ich.
Ja.
Gut, Herr Emre.
Ja, da ist er.